I'm sure we've all at one point in our
lives watched or read an anime or manga
that we really felt we had a connection
with something that spoke to us on a
deeper level for whatever reason that
maybe perhaps it reminded us of an
experience we had in our lives or
conveyed a message we really understood
or had some characters you could totally
empathize with because of here we ended
up growing a deep attachment to the
point where no matter what flaws the
thing may actually have we could easily
overlook it because well it didn't
matter
it didn't affect our experience or why
we got so attached to it and even if
others did find flaws with it
we didn't care as they didn't have the
same experience that you did to us it
was perfect
even if objectively speaking the perfect
anime the perfect game the perfect movie
cannot exist
recently I was lucky enough to be able
to see the record breaking your name in
theatres and it absolutely blew me away
so much so I had to watch it not twice
but three times for getting close to
satisfied and it was after I walked out
the theater for the third time that I
knew I'd found my new perfect anime
except I know that critically speaking
if I called this perfect or a
masterpiece or any other overly
superlative adjectives there would be
those of us who would argue the
semantics of describing it such a way
cuz at the end of the day it's an
opinion that's subjective and I don't
know why this word is so looked down
upon when we were talking critically
about something of course I know the
film isn't perfect the characters aren't
the deepest moments of it can play off
melodrama and I'm sure if I thought
deeply about it I can find plot holes
because the film speaks the heart rather
than to the mind though none of that
actually matters to me because I felt it
achieved everything it needed to and
there is so much I love about this film
that I wouldn't change a single thing
about it I can't remember the last time
I saw something with so much charm and
beauty to wear and there's not just one
single thing I could point out to say
why I love this movie the beautiful
dichotomy of the lives of two
star-crossed lovers learning vicariously
about one another
capturing the carefree nature of
adolescents like that melancholic
feeling of watching a long summers day
passing by that dreamlike quality of
longing for something that seems
preordained yet lost while mixing in
themes of fantasy long-distance
relationships and natural disaster
somehow weaving all this into a
compelling narrative there are so many
elements blending together to create a
piece of work that spokes me on so many
levels that went beyond just breaking
down characters animation writing and
music I walked out the theater with the
same bittersweet joy of meeting a lost
friend you will see again for a long
time with a reignited passion for this
medium I love so much and that's not one
thing you can just put on a 1 to 10
review scale to me it was a masterpiece
and no matter plotholes character
writing or melodrama could take that
away from me but I know that not
everyone will share the same experience
I did or come to the same conclusion
there will be people who didn't appeal
to some will have gotten too caught up
in the hype or simply couldn't connect
to it as much for whatever reason and
that's fine no one will ever create a
piece of work that would appeal to
absolutely everybody so why is it that
we pretend a good review something that
can objectively break down what makes a
piece of media good or not many
self-proclaimed critics I've seen always
hard back to the writing and characters
as the absolute backbone of what makes
something good as if there's only one
specific formula to making a great show
which is something I totally disagree
with sure there is a guidebook and
theories to what makes good filmmaking a
storytelling which applies to the
majority but we shouldn't forget what
they are a guide not an absolute and
there are exceptions to every rule every
anime sets out to achieve something
different and part of the charm of
certain movies or shows is the way they
are able to impress you even if it
clearly has flaws or sometimes even
embracing them we say show don't tell
then along comes the Monica Tree series
showing us that we can craft an
interesting story almost entirely
through dialogue if characters in
writing were all that mattered then we
wouldn't get things like the
mind-blowing visual extravaganza that
was redline gurren lagaan came to
celebrate the cheesy horror tropes we
all thought we were tired of and the
ending of Evangelion was such a raw
unfiltered outcry of emotion that love
it or hate it has remained a topic of
discussion and a res
nating moment for many people to this
day so what is it that really makes the
show mean something to us the conclusion
I've come to is that there is no single
technique that portrays this but there
is a common driving force I've felt from
all of these shows passion and
communication at the end of the day
anime is a form of art a way for the
creators to communicate to the audience
in some way whether it be an idea or
feeling and experience or something else
and my favorite shows are the ones where
this communication really resonated with
me maybe it was a hype scene a beautiful
moment a genius piece of writing and I'm
sure you all have your own personal
examples which is why I feel like the
best critics are people who can break
down why a movie or anime appeals to
them and what aspects of it would appeal
to an individual audience member rather
than a blanket statement of wise
objectively good nothing about this is
objective so instead of condemning
subjectivity why aren't we embracing it
most of my favorite ever shows had
nothing to do with taking off some
predetermined categories but some
aspects of feeling that I really liked
about it
recently I've seen an increase in people
embracing the critical analysis of anime
which is great you know there's nothing
wrong with promoting a smarter way of
looking at a medium but I think in doing
so I feel we've created a community that
uphol is having a higher knowledge and
appreciation of the inner workings
behind your favorite shows more than
just having fun it is possible to
embrace critical thinking while
acknowledging the subjectivity of it so
we may joke about it but there's
certainly no such thing as a bad taste
in anime in fact I think the worst thing
you can do is either keep a closed mind
or alter your taste so it's more
respectable I've seen far too many
people try to hide the actual tastes
because they think it's too mainstream
or too trashy or something that isn't
critically acclaimed there's nothing
wrong with your favorite anime even if
it doesn't take all the boxes and
characters or writing or cinematography
or if you just like it for some really
stupid reason and it's definitely
nothing wrong with thinking some
critically acclaimed shows are just
boring as hell
if you can unashamedly say hey I just
really like this trashy show because it
was trashy or the more power to you I
unashamedly hold love hina close to me
because it reminds me of a time when my
adolescence romance
as the concept of just finding a partner
who would accept me and every so often
another show comes along that just
appeals to that side of me even if I
know it's absolutely trashy your tastes
reflect who you are as a person your
interests are shaped by your experiences
and upbringing that made you the
individual you are today so why the hell
shouldn't you be proud of that it
shouldn't be about having superior taste
it shouldn't be about showing off how
much knowledge you have and it
definitely shouldn't be about showing
how much smarter you are than other
people it should be about keeping an
open mind embracing individuality and
most of all having fun I'm the type of
guy who can be gawping at the complex
narrative presentations seen as Satoshi
Kon to work and then arguing over which
Monica trigo has the most appealing bust
in the same conversation in fact those
were some of the most interesting
conversations I've ever had with some of
the most interesting people I've ever
had the pleasure of meeting whatever
shows hold a special place in your heart
are special because that's the person
you are so don't forget that and I guess
all I really wanted to say through all
this mindless rambling without any real
point I was trying to make was that I
saw an anime the other day and I liked
it a lot it was pretty great
no in fact it was perfect
ah chika ksama kimi no nioi ghaseeta
Haruki gotta say moe
so no our egoic a cheetah
[Music]